bonjour à tous bienvenue à sept autres
éditions dc espace autochtone en direct
je m'appelle anne-marie vont vous savez
la semaine passée on a parlé de musique
et la basse et la saison c'est la saison
de la littérature
alors on va en profiter pour passer une
super émission avec des invités tout
aussi superbe qui écrivent des romans
absolument étonnant pour certains plus
prévisible peut-être pour d'autres on
veut voir mais de toute façon on aura
l'embarras du choix aujourd'hui alors je
vous les présente surtout que celle qui
est assise à côté de moi isabelle notre
habitués de l'émission est aussi une
écrivaine isabelle picard bonjour
bonjour c'est peut-être beaucoup d'eux
est remis en cause lui jeunes enfants
une première un premier roman
exactement et lyon on veut en entendre
parler donc on va y revenir c'est sûr au
cours des prochaines minutes
julie kurtness julie bonjourbonjour
julie vous êtes l'auteur de deux romans
de vengeance le premier oui que vous
avez sorti je pense en 2010 est un acte
de vengeance
voilà où le voit bien et puis elle tout
nouveau à d'ailleurs de vengeance a été
publié en anglais aussi oui ce serait
sorti fin septembre en inde
oui exactement et puis le second qui est
sorti il ya quelques semaines
aquarium qui nous amène dans un tout
autre univers que celui de de vengeance
d'ailleurs donc on va pouvoir en parler
alors bienvenue bienvenue parmi nous et
merci de me recevoir
et puis nous allons à québec parce que
notre invité était en route vers le
salon du livre de rimouski où il va
aller présenter son nouvel ouvrage aussi
ces coucous mme michèle jean mongeau
michel oui bonjour on recommande alors
michel on va parler de votre ouvrage
aussi qui nous amène sur le territoire
de vos ancêtres donc ça va faire partie
de notre discussion mais on va ouvrir
une discussion beaucoup plus large que
ça parce que l'intérêt c'est de parler
de littérature mais doit-on parler
absolument de littérature autochtone
quand on est un autochtone on ne sait
pas qu'il est le premier qui a envie d'y
répondre
julie quand on parle de quand on parle
de vous comme écrivaine
est ce que vous êtes content de dire de
que vous êtes une écrivaine autochtone
est ce que c'est important
bah oui c'est important parce que c'est
fondamental à mon identité je suis
autochtone je suis écrivaine donc les
écrivains autochtones mélo où j'ai
peut-être des rides sens et quand on dit
ça en pensant que ce que j'écris va
avoir nécessairement e lle avec les
enjeux ou l'item qu'on associe
habituellement avec les autochtones mais
j'ai aucun problème en fait je suis très
fier d'être haute en autochtone oui
parce que c'est pas parce qu'on doit
faire une littérature qui porte
seulement sur des enjeux des thèmes
autochtone mais voilà michel reppelin
manière avec un pardon qu'un écrivain
québécois
les projets décrire exactement toujours
des histoires qui se passe sur le
plateau et projets des grès des romans
qui ont trait à la réalité québécoise
on a cette ouverture là mais on a la
même ouverture pour les autochtones moi
j'écris des romans qui parfois très de
la réalité autochtone mais parfois très
d'autres choses parfois ça permet de
mettre simplement dans un roman comme
par exemple mon rama précédent qui
s'appelle tsunami se déroule pendant les
événements du tsunami en 2000 2005
et oui on est avec les tigres tamouls ça
aucun rapport avec la route comme le
personnage qui est un journaliste tabac
est un autochtone donc un moment donné
ça lui donne un autre regard sur la
crise et les tensions au soudan contre
les tamouls entre les cinghalais alors
ça peut être plusieurs choses ça peut
être vraiment d'aborder avec un regard
autochtone des situations qui concernent
les autochtones ça fait simplement
d'avoir un point de vue légèrement
différent vous sap est simplement d'être
un autochtone qui écrit comme jules il
dit des fois on peut on peut créer autre
chose et être autochtone parce que sinon
c'est comme si on ne pouvait quitter sur
un sujet oui absolument limitatif en
plus isabelle on connaît pas encore
votre premier ouvrage mais en tant
qu'écrivaine autochtone est ce que vous
êtes parti dans la
le contemporain qu'est ce que vous avez
pris comme tel ben en fait je suis parti
de la prémisse qu'on commence à écrire
sur ce qu'on connaît c'est beaucoup plus
facile et bien vous connaissez un puma
mission maintenant c'est se créer des
ponts entre les autochtones et les
allochtones
donc c'est sûr que tous ceux à mijoter
dans mon roman
ça va être vraiment jeunesse donc il
veut s'adresser aux douces et environs
et qui se passe à la fois dans une
communauté très éloignées et dans une
communauté urbaine et donc qui raconte
l'histoire de deux jumeaux donc ça va
être
oui ça même dans dans l'élément
autochtone bien sûr mais ce sont aussi
des jeunes de leur temps donc ils vont
pas juste écouter du cache t-il de notre
pays vont donc c'est vraiment ils vont
vivre aujourd'hui dans le québec de
joutes
ok d'accord alors il ya beaucoup de
salons du livre qui se déroule cette
semaine on vous avait été invité au
temps julie que michel a participé à
différents événements
à rimouski michel je pense que vous
assistez vous allez participer à des
tables rondes bon de faire aussi
ailleurs quand on vous invite dans des
événements bon comme le salon du livre
de rimouski est ce qu'on vous invite en
tant qu'autochtones qui va traiter d'un
sujet qui va intéresser autochtones et
non autochtones est ce qu'on vous
demande de vous exprimer sur un sujet
qui vous concernent particulièrement bas
ce soit parfois il ya des activités qui
ont lieu en marge d'un salon du livre
mais parfois on demande aux autochtones
de participer ou dans des débats sur des
questions qui vont qui ont touché les
autochtones mais pas nécessaire mais je
dirais la réalité des données clients
d'octobre c'est un peu la même réalité
comme n'importe quel autre écurie la
josiane c'est l'imaginaire c'est des
thèmes qu'on veut aborder à la quatre
voies dans les salons du livre
ça peut ça peut varier d'une fois à
l'autre à dépendre celle de salon aussi
dans les salons par exemple quand on va
je me souviens d'être allé au salon du
livre
sept-îles évidemment on est collé sur la
communauté de wash est un lieu où
tottenham là bas il y avait beaucoup du
new money on a fait un atelier sur la
littérature autochtone et ça m'a fait
plaisir de voir que c'est la technique
et bâtir le plus de gens au salon du
livre de sept îles et avait beaucoup de
détenus qui s'étaient déplacés pour la
citation parce que pour la première fois
j'avais l'impression d'être partie
prenante
selon hala mai à rimouski c'est aussi
autre chose et parfois cdc simplement
parler de littérature avec des lecteurs
avec des gens qui sont là ou si c'est
moi tentons se demander est ce que c'est
important de définir comme autochtones
moi au départ alors jeunes gens
parlaient pas
pour deux raisons et notamment parce que
dans mon travail je trouve que ça il y
avait des préjugés souvent quand j'ai
commencé à travailler qui fait que moi
j'étais devant sa pas en parler c'est un
vieux journaliste 15 ans bien sûr nous
donnons je fais des blagues non mais oui
la fameuse phrase à michel l'histoire
d'un indien s'intéresse personne ne l'a
entendu dans plusieurs stations à
plusieurs moments dans ma vie il ya
plusieurs époques comme journaliste je
lâchais pas encore récemment
mais ce que je voulais j'ai commencé
plus en parler à partir du moment où
justement je me suis rendu compte que
fallait aussi affirmer la présence et
que certaines valeurs pour les gens qui
vivent dans les communautés parce que
quand tu es je sais pas - à natashquan
ben il se frotte à temps parlé d une ou
des autochtones c'est quand il est pour
les femmes autochtones assassinées ou
disparues cadets les pommes dans les
communautés ces terrains donc de
permettre de dire aux gens voilà il ya
une présence qui là bas ça s'peut moment
donné quelques moyens de photo ap ça
mais tf1
un genre de da mois dans le passage avec
mes limites cherchant auteurs
autochtones qui m'avait super et ému
pourquoi parce que la professeure vous
essaierez de se produire voyage capable
d'écrire vous aussi des jeunes donc je
pense qu'il ya un rapport complet qui
est important pour que les gens le
voient mais d'abord pour que les gens de
la communauté autochtone le voit mais en
même temps la façon dont ces reçus c'est
quand quand tu t'en vas dans 1 1
un salon c'est ce que seulement 4 des
gens pensent aux torts autochtone mais
il pense que tu vois nécessairement
parler du territoire parler de tout ça
on peut mais pas que mais pas que
exactement julie quand vous êtes invités
dans les salons est ce qu'on vous
identifier ou et catégorise
automatiquement comme auteur autochtone
en fait ça dépend du salon ça dépend du
sujet du lit où ça dépend du contexte
donc les 2 me sont arrivées évidemment
c'est sûr que si on va quoi y attendre
le salon du livre des premières nations
mais on et rotaract acteurs nourris
ça tourne autour un peu de ce thème le
met par exemple je m'en veux salon du
livre de montréal dans ce monde aussi
dans tout cela
ça arrive je table ronde sur je crois c
sur le nord donc parce que mon dernier
livre traite de ce thème là bas ils
s'investissent
donc je la paye du nord en itéra tu
exactement donc je pense que ça dépend
beaucoup de ce contexte puisque je peux
pas me prononcer sur ce qui se passait à
vin parce que moussa fait juste deux ans
que j'ai commencé à publier mais je
pense qu'en ce moment il ya une
effervescence de littérature autochtones
ayant un intérêt dans la littérature
autochtones donc c'est peut-être pour ça
que les salons du livre
il met en place des tables rondes ou des
conférences avec ce sujet là parce que
il ya un intérêt pour la population
aussi c'est de là que ça vient parce que
moi je les constate et il est un peu
plus vieux que je mets xhaka cas on
avait mon premier roman qui parle à des
questions à tocane s'appelle elle
et nous pendant ma grand mère betty
soieries aimé ma cousine à ce moment là
je me suis fait les le manuscrit puis à
12h tu se reprendre un titre en images
non parce que si je donne un sens inouï
il ya beaucoup de gens qui m'ont parlé
par préjugé et moi ce que je veux c'est
en lisant le lire les gens changent leur
regard
puis quand on note publiée à -7 en 2016
donc on est quatre à plus tard seulement
je vais encore un nom en français en
tête
antichi moment donné c'est joséphine
bacon kedia michel ce livre de ces beaux
restes et un rassemblement c'est un
amour joie à moins on va l'appeler à
monter des rares chez joseph était
contente assuriez là mais on appelait à
main et moi je pense que ça aux contrats
aidés le
lee le libyen d'aytré dit encore et
basta leur était vendu beaucoup plus
compenser continue encore de trouver des
lecteurs été publié cet automne en
france va être publié au mois de mars en
autriche en allemagne devrait publier au
moins deux matches aussi au canada
anglais et ça puisque ça montre c'est
que il s'est passé des choses comme la
commission de réconciliation des gens
ont été sensibilisés le dossier des
femmes autochtones de dossiers des
pensionnats autochtones l'opinion
publique bouge et commencent à regarder
et surtout moi je dirais les jeunes des
jeunes regards devraient vraiment un
point de vue plus intéressé par rapport
à toutes ces questions la conséquence
dans la société des jeunes s'intéressent
une chose mais souvent c'est ce que doit
être un vecteur et c'est pour ça que je
pense qu'il ya un plus grand intérêt
maintenant dans les salons du livre
ailleurs et c'est parce que le public
est là je regarde le nom me fontaine
était dans les best-sellers qu'aucun a
fait aussi des selles ça n'a pas été le
cas il ya 10 ans elle aujourd'hui
pourquoi parce que le public est plus
prêt maintenant oui c'est pour ça que
vous n'avez pas été intimidé de
l'appeler coup comme cet autre salaire
soit pour moi oui mais si je veux dire
grand mère l'avait salaire soit pour moi
si j'étais content de pouvoir la faire
je pensais qu'au contraire c'était le
titre qui était le plus approprié pour
le nid une vie et en même temps ben en
même temps moi j'aime le fait de pouvoir
mettre un peu de langues autochtones
dans les vitrines et dans le coeur des
gens alors oui mais en même temps il ya
dix ans même c'était différent
aujourd'hui on est rendu là parce que
les québécois ils sont pas juste les
québécois des accidents touchent dirait
une plus grande ouverture ce camp du oui
alors j'ai appris comme ça que
lac-saint-jean c'était quoi camou le pkk
mais des couacs amis oui pourquoi kelly
exactement j'avais pensé me mais j'ai
dit oui mais oui c'est vrai en plus oui
m et qu'aucun par contre ce n'est pas
votre grand-mère là puisque dans le
roman on parle de votre arrière grand
mère
bien sûr cette façon parce que je t'aime
en jeu d'un personnage de
je remets mon arrière grand mère a
demandé mais on a eu une vie mais
c'était peut-être même l'histoire de ma
famille que je trouve intéressante mais
plutôt de me servir de l'histoire de ma
famille pour raconter le l'histoire des
hinault et surtout la fin du mode de vie
traditionnel des conséquences de
sédentarisation forcée des pensionnaires
et intérêts pour que quand les lecteurs
québécois en trop aussi au regard de la
situation actuelle
puis il voit une communauté souvent vont
porter des jugements rayé des raisons
historiques est ce qu'il est une
situation dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui donc je me sers de ma
famille dans le fond de mon arrière
grand mère allemande pour que le lecteur
après soir et ajuste émotivement des
situations et change son regard parce
que moi je suis quelqu'un qui pense que
c'est la grand pouvoir de littérature on
s'adresse au coeur des gens on est dans
leurs esprits en deux dans leur tête
on est capable de leur parler d'une
manière plus intime qu'on fait quand on
était la télévision par exemple il ya
moins d'impact ça s'adresse à moins que
jamais sucre sont visés sont touchés
dans leur chair
alors c'est ce pouvoir délivrer je fais
pour faire à bord tout cas si un livre
qui a du pouvoir c'est celui de julie
aussi entre autres de vengeance entre
autres parce que c'est vraiment un livre
marquant c'est votre premier mais il a
été il a été encensé par la critique
c'est un polar faut le dire quand même
alors quand on quand on parlait de le
pouvoir qu'on a dans l'esprit des gens
vous avez un grand pouvoir avec celui là
en fait j'étais surprise qu'on qualifie
mon premier roman de panda en fait moi
je n'avais pas du tout je n'avais pas du
tout écrit dans ce top six clubs je
voudrais même mon éditeur on était
surpris qu'ils soient classés pas là
donc
wes la réception d'olive est toujours
comment dire faut lâcher prise il faut
quand même que je dirais que je voulais
faire ça faire absolument arié donc est
ce que le livre un pouvoir sûrement mais
en même temps le pouvoir que le livre
est indépendant de l'auteur dans le sens
où ce rendu là c'est plus de mauvaises
mains donc tant mieux si ça a un impact
mais moi je suis très axé sur les arts
dans son sujet j'ai eu du plaisir à
l'écrire
j'espère que les gens vont du plaisir à
lire moi ce que je souhaitais écrire un
livre que les gens allaient ml et je
pense que j'ai réussi mon but alors est
ce qui est bon il ya eu des bonnes
critiques
je vous trouve un peu généreuse quand
vous quittez encensé par la critique
mais mais quand même j'ai dû comme
critique en tout cas était très élogieux
ouais c'est vrai j'ai peut être critique
négative maintenant sa peau de sa peau
tout casser non plus de sa personne une
première oeuvre qui disent que tout le
monde ne l'a pas lu encore c'est tout le
monde ne l'a pas lu encore ce même temps
ça reste une première erreur une
première oeuvre ce serait parfait parce
qu'on veut tous mais est ce qu'on a dans
la tête de puits
depuis qu'on a envie d'écrire donc
ça donne oui mais est-ce que un jour un
prochain livre pourrait parce que je
regardais jamais on ne lit le mourre
autochtone jamais eu aucune référence
on ne peut absolument pas le savoir dans
un aquarium ça commence un peu à changer
légèrement ouais ouais il ya des
personnages oui en certaine ascendance
autochtone mais ça reste en attendant on
dit dans ces pôles commentaire sur ce
que le thème de l'identité est pour
quelque chose qui me préoccupe que
motard maurice dans le sens où dans ma
vie personnelle winch 13 ans se bat ce
méme état avant d'écrire je me dise pas
rom mois autochtone comment je vais
écrire ses appareils la flotte c'est moi
ce beau du tout ça c'est vraiment des
histoires que je porte en moi puis
évidemment qui est mon identité
autochtone doit faire en sorte que j'ai
certaines sensibilités où j'ai envers
certains personnages vont vers certaines
situations mais c'est pas systématique
c'est pas quelque chose de conscient
mais qui je veux que je fais donc ce
n'est pas comme souvent on s'en rend pas
compte
moi un moment donné ça me dit tout ce
que tu écris concerne l'identité
le mulhousien jeu jamais pensé à ça et
je vais penser à ce truc là sur patins
pour l hymne ou là où vraiment mais si
je te renvoie des zoos et sa demoiselle
salle a frappé ce que je sais c'est que
entre ce qu il ya de ça on écrit on fait
les choses mais on n'est pas d'un snack
conscient on n'a pas la même perception
de comment ça va être perçue par les
autres à la même si on a l'impression
des fois que l'identité par exemple pour
un sujet que tu abordes tu peut
l'aborder mal malgré toi puisque pour sa
couronne invasion mais les gens ont une
perception différente de nos rames ans
que nous on a moins sujet mon premier à
main des gens l'avaient traité de pala
qui
voilà voilà
mais je peux comprendre que quelqu'un
sait qu'il ya des différences l'api le
moteur on écrit avec ce qu'on a des
muscles en date dans sa masse qui reçoit
andorre toujours exactement de la même
manière alors pour moi je pense que ce
soit entre la perception côté rock la
perception que le public à il ya souvent
une différence qui nous met mal à l'aise
nous aussi des fois il s'appelle comment
va le qualifier votre premier fast
premier roman c'est une bonne question
je pense que c'est un roman qui va être
très très près de la réalité pour moi ça
c'est essentiel puis y'a pas juste une
réalité autochtone y en a plusieurs
donc c'était vraiment important pour moi
de montrer un peu là la réalité dans des
communautés très éloignés mais aussi
dans des communautés urbaines et on peut
faire la différence entre les deux où il
ya encore des lieux aussi des points
communs donc les relever j'espère qu'il
va être appréciée des jeunes mais je
pense qu'il va pouvoir être lu par les
moins jeunes et il va s'appeler comment
il va s'appeler rsa c'est une primeur
naples est mené c'est en langue et nous
donc ça veut dire deux ça veut aussi
dire venez jeter aussi une expression
autochtone dont on est on est souvent
dit ça quand on est né chez la mère de
s'exprimer la manière dont l'humour ou
six autres jeunes qui teinte donc ce
qu'on dit comment on est donc c'est
vraiment une manière d'être autochtone
jeunesse écrit n é s h tremblements h
chacun d'eux parce que ses deux jumeaux
est longue
oui voilà alors là on va se tourner vers
d'autres écrivains parce que évidemment
la littérature autochtone et on disait
avant l'émission commence elle est de
plus en plus présentes à ce qu'il ya de
plus en plus d'écrivains d'auteurs dont
trice avez vous l'impression qu'il y en
a de plus en plus
oui mais au canada ah oui parce que il
ya les autres acteurs ne sont plus
nombreux au canada au québec il ya c'est
quelque chose qui est en émergence
il ya des vieux de la vieille l'action
là depuis longtemps
puis toute une génération qui est ici de
cette génération militante ou plus
politisés
je pense qu'il va en avoir beaucoup qui
vont émerger aujourd'hui encore plus oui
il ya plus de mauvaises ce qui est
intéressant pour pour les plus jeunes
moi quand j'étais jeune j'ai toujours
dit j'ai étudié en littérature mais et
j'avais pas de modèle exact
on avait beau y en a plein et donc
vraiment bon et michel qui a rendu à
quoi dix ou onze romans jeunesse non 7,8
natasha khan ap fontanesi films dont ils
ont besoin
les thèmes abordés veille il était jeune
radio puis hors micro le journal qui
était avec avec jeu je serai l'addition
se disent quelque chose mais un peu
chocs et une demande est dit soit ils
attaquent la nasa part de taxe
territoire du parc
non j'ai dit non d'abord au nom du
progrès ça s'appelle un peu j'ai mal
mais j'ai dit faut ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que nous notre histoire
elle existe est nulle part dans les
livres alors c'est normal que les
autochtones au départ commencent à
s'intéresser à des questions comme celle
là où il est c'est notre dame année ça
commence déjà
je dirais julie sa part rapport avec
l'exil le territoire etc
moi je mérite qu'on parlera pas mon
prochain roman va se passer avec des
autochtones urbain avec la réalité des
autochtones d'urbain ouidah coup comme
je parle de la fin du mode de vie
traditionnel
cette autorisation force et c'est quoi
y'a personne que l'écrit cette histoire
là y'a personne qui a raconté comment
les autochtones surtout l'ont vécu
commun ça a été perçu par ado qu'est ce
que ça a eu comme conséquence d'excision
l'écrit 3,7 soit d'ailleurs pas parce
qu'ils vendent cher comme on l'a fait
mais après ça veut dire ça évolue sa
voie vers autre chose on retrouve
toujours un conte et la même histoire
dans chacun nourrit donc avec avec la
multiplication des os travaux savoir la
multiplication des points de vue
et puis position et moi sur ce front
isabelle maeght ne parlant que de son
livre ses parents pêche au super parce
que ça se passe dans des communautés se
passe en ville des jeunes qui rétablit
avec des jeunes qui ont il ne fait
encore donc ça veut dire que les jeunes
qui vont les belles
notre projet a cédé récupérer quand on
est adulte environnement avec son jean
volet vont être sensibilisés ils vont
avoir eu surtout entre un contrat car
moi je pense qu'au contraire c'est c'est
eh oui alors c'est ça on disait donc ils
sont beaucoup plus nombreux au canada
anglais mais il y a beaucoup d'émergence
du côté du du québec et dans plusieurs
styles
oui parce qu'évidemment il ya le roman
mais il ya aussi l'écriture de pièces de
théâtre ça en fait partie il y a aussi
les essais et puis il ya la poésie oui
et je pense que vous avez relevé
plusieurs auteurs certains qui sont
émergents mais d'autres qui sont déjà
bien implantés oui bien sûr dans les
très bien implanté on pense tout ce
talent joséphine bacon on pense à
natasha khan ap fontaine à rita
mestokosho à marie-andrée gueule quand
même nourrir quelques quelques recueils
mais j'ai plusieurs années la wii 6 7 8
ans à peu près et donc mes dents il ya
beaucoup d'auteurs émergents puis c'est
un peu d'eux que j'avais envie de vous
parler aujourd'hui notamment le premier
m'a en fait moi je le connais bien c'est
pierrot ross tremblay qui a publié son
premier recueil chez mémoire d'encrier
mémoire d'encrier fait qu'ils publient
énormément de poètes autochtone et donc
ça a été publié cette année ça s'appelle
nipi manitou va donc me pisser haut et
manitou esprit donc l'esprit de l'eau et
sa présente une poésie qui est à la fois
spirituel mystique et quand on décrit
comme étant écrites dans l'urgence de
tout dire
donc ça et pour connaître pierrot ross
pour moi je trouve ça ça lui ressemble
liu yang a d'ailleurs gagné d'ailleurs
un prix le prix voix autochtone pour
projet d'en littéraire autochtone déjà
avec ce recueil de poésie là et le
second c'est celui de maria cousineau
marlène qui s'appelle bréviaire du
matricule 0,82
que j'ai parcouru également un petit peu
moins moins long je connais également un
maya et on la reconnaît dans ce livre
y'a dangereux que il a en fait on y
reconnaît son affirmation son
affirmation de femmes
on reconnaît aussi d élan de colère oui
donc ça c'est quand même assez
intéressant aussi à ce niveau là donc à
découvrir
et elle parle du fait aussi de sa
féminité du fait d'être une femme
autochtone est là en poésie dernièrement
on a plusieurs recueils qui tourne
autour du terme de des femmes
autochtones qu'est-ce que disparus
assassinés de la main oui et c'est le
code de sylvain rivard donc avec son
recueil les poupées donc cette info
recueil mais il ya différentes parties
différentes sections il va aussi aller
dans la mythologie pour parler des
femmes autochtones assez intéressant aux
éditions et nora qui est quand même un
éditeur ne pas oublier c'est la maison
d'édition basée à un ami c'est l'humain
donc j'en suis au publié la levée car le
picard soumis également donc y en a
plusieurs
auriez vous pu publier la julie en fait
c'est quand j'ai choisi mon histoire je
me suis pas demandé si je voulais un
territoire autochtone ouais en fait que
je lis ce que j'ai fait c'est est-ce que
tout autant devrait faire c'est regarder
quelle maison d'édition une écurie
d'auteur qui ressemble le plus à autant
ou à au sujet ou à nos écrits finalement
nous on se reconnaît donc
je vous avoue tout en toute candeur que
j'ai même papa oui me trouver un éditeur
autochtone oui parce que vous êtes à
l'instant même pour vos deux ouvrages
michel vous vous êtes chez libre
expression en tout cas pour celui là
mais passionnante mais au même groupe
l'a un peu comme julie en fait qu'un
public je vais être dans un
environnement où ça correspond à ce que
tu écris mais oui je dirais serait
peut-être à ya aussi mais moi je suis
avec eux depuis le début comme je suis
assez fidèle en amitié je savais que
dakhla avec le temps mais c'est même si
ce n'est pas deux maisons d'édition qui
autochtone incertain mais ont quand même
montré beaucoup d'ouverture quand je
vous dis un monde qui était le premier
recueil de nouvelles par des auteurs
patois comme suit mon éditrice a trouvé
excellent tapis ils ont embarqué alors
j'ai toujours senti une ouverture je
serai pas senti je serais pas resté
oui absolument et gens sont ouverts oui
il avait vous allez publier chez qui les
malins donc c'est une maison d'une
maison d'édition jeunesse l'art est
dynamique vraiment les propriétaires
sont jeunes
ça se sent ça va être je pense super
intéressant mais j'ai eu la chance
d'être approché par différentes maisons
d'édition dans la dernière année
probablement du fait que j'écris des
chroniques chez tes robes et elles
étaient toutes non autochtone donc il ya
vraiment un intérêt aussi de la part des
maisons d'édition pour publier
oui c'est rassurant c'est important
aussi alors on continue dans la liste
des dix hic des dépôts est en fait je
voulais juste renchérit ont peut-être
sur le thème des femmes autochtones
disparues ou assassinées moyens on
recueille qui m'a beaucoup plu cette
année qui s'appelle en marche pour cindy
qui est écrit par virginie à bord de
l'eau qui est une artiste cris
multidisciplinaire c'est pas son premier
recueil mai
j'ai trouvé que c'était vraiment
affirmer engagé et bon cindy c'est
l'histoire de ces niveaux là où ce qui
est une de ces femmes autochtones
disparues et assassinées
ll est disparue à val-d'or en 2014 donc
le terme vraiment des femmes autochtones
on le retrouve boom dans la poésie dont
dans le sentier dans l'univers des
dépôts est autochtone toujours par des
femmes poètes autochtone assez souvent
un meilleur sylvain camélia sylvain wiki
qui sort du lot en essonne
ok on pourrait tout de suite passer aux
essais parce que il ya aussi d'ailleurs
avant d'aller plus loin connaissez-vous
tous ces poètes et ses auteurs
autochtone est ce que dans la dans la
communauté on sait qui est là sur le
terrain c'est instinctivement d'un fake
oui on est quand même court 1 2 qui fait
quoi
mais en même temps c'est le temps et
tonnes dans les rares où j'étais qui lui
la moitié des auteurs dont on parle
encore de tous les rois mages c'est de
lire - roman ou de chaque auteur e
attaque que je connais pour moi savoir
qu'est ce qui s'écrit qu'est ce que les
gens disent avoir une idée si on veut
dans de survol c'est quoi la production
des auteurs
ce que vous voyez vous rassure vous
satisfait comment vous vous sentez quand
vous voyez de travail fait par les
autres moi je trouve qu'il ya plein de
bons auteurs attaquant déjà dans toutes
sortes de styles je prends pas mal oui
car mika ciani oui qui lui écrit des
romans
un peu déjanté et julie qui elle a un
côté un peu noir aussi à moi qui va
écrire dans un soin de soi des suspenses
politiques ou des romains plus intimiste
des gens comme sylvain dont on parle
tantôt il ya déjà une grande variété
puis une grande qualité parce que en
réalité c'est pas parce que tu es
autochtone qu'on vote publié par ce que
les autochtones que lui le public les
instants le que tout le monde doit être
plus indulgent de la main c'est pas bon
c'est pas bon c'est pas bon sa fille
fait la barre est à la même hauteur pour
tout le monde autochtone ils doivent
arriver à même hauteur de bas et donc
nécessairement ce qui arrive à cette
hauteur de ben à la baisse parce qu'ils
sont yo yo yo yo soy ans est anase
capacités puis ils font des livres sont
de grande qualité mais quand même je
dirais qu'en poésie c'est là qu'on est
les plus forts pour l'instant bon c'est
joséphine qui vient d'être honoré je
pense à natacha aussi beaucoup lu canapé
fontaine oui je pense qu'il ya une
logique à ce que ça commence par la
poésie aussi parce qu'on est des peuples
de tradition orale
s'esclaffe bouillir c'est ça la poésie
et tenir tes ratures de l'oralité on l a
déclamé jeu quand tu dit natacha qu'un
ep fontaine tu là ta parole et oui quand
je la vois dans un spectacle déclamer
ses poèmes ses elle dit
joseph m c'est un peu la même chose sur
un autre ton complètement à ce moment là
donc il ya une certaine logique à ce que
les la brèche des premières brèches se
soit fait par la poésie puisqu'elle
beaucoup de gens qui soit tournée vers
la poésie parce que c'est très près de
ce que les de l'héritage culturel des
autochtones
mais en même temps je pense la deuxième
vague après c'est par la littérature
qu'elle va s'imposer parce que toutes
ces histoires qu'on raconte est qui
était longue avant qu'ils prennent un
bain ça ne peut pas le faire seulement
par la poésie et la littérature seul va
permettre alors je pense que c'est en
deux temps toujours vont rester très
présente la poésie est proche mais en
même temps je pense que beaucoup
d'auteurs qui vont vouloir utiliser la
littérature pour oui on peut et on doit
aussi divertir moi j'en suis comme je
dis je que les gens s'amusent en âmes au
lit mais en même temps ça permet de
d'explorer d'étain du chien que ont peu
à voir avec notre propre
je regardais vous êtes beaucoup
d'écrivains il nous innu wendat pas
beaucoup d'atika mecque des crises est
plus difficile bon parce que leur
première langue souvent en fait leur
deuxième langue est l'anglais micmacs
pas beaucoup non plus que je me trompe
ben je pense c'est l'enjeu de la langue
oui c'est c'est beaucoup ce donc
peut-être qu'ils écrivent en anglais
puis il ya deux seuls étudiants nadeau
les auteurs anglophones on entend
beaucoup moins parler dans l'espace des
coûts système médiatique qui
traversaient sur les auteurs
francophones dont peut-être pour ça
qu'on en entend moins parler puis demain
si la france est la troisième langue
c'est difficile après cela de décrire
une troisième langue commune ont aussi
quand même il sait on est plus nombreux
donc oui le serment jeudi
mathématiquement on va avoir plus de
hauteur au moins de nous puis et puis
comme je les dis la langue et wendat
jeudi la langue est plus maîtrisée chez
les wanna de france est vrai que dans
certaines communautés qui sont encore un
territoire et c'est donc nécessairement
avoir plus de gens qui vont vous qui
vont être disposés près tu sais mais ça
ça va changer avec le temps aussi parce
que ça va avec l'éducation ça va avec
puis ça c'est un phénomène qui est en
train d'évoluer aussi c'est la force du
nombre qui fait que ce ça prend un
certain nombre de cantons un certain
nombre de personnes qui sont utilisés
qui sont dans un environnement
littéraire il voit émerger de son
certain nombre d'auteurs
oui puis on arrive mais c'est normal ça
commence à redoubler wendat france a
promis à cause du nombre des nous qu'à
cause de l'histoire
alors parlons des essais maintenant
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'auteurs
autochtones qui se sont lancés dans
l'essai au québec
oui oui et c'est mon genre littéraire
préféré alors j'en ai lu plusieurs le
premier dont je vous parle c'est un
livre de zébédée young hak qui est un
ebook du nunavik en fait oui et donc lui
il a écrit un essai qui s'intitule
contre le colonialisme dopé aux
stéroïdes super intéressant le titre dit
tout et on n'est pas déçu qu'on lit
c'est un livre qui se lit en une section
2 heures 3 heures si vous prenez votre
temps vraiment qu'il va qui va parler de
l'épisode des grands projets
hydroélectriques au québec donc lui
était un ego siata à l'intérieur de ces
grands projets leur entourant la fameuse
convention de la baie james qu'on
connaît oui et il va décret est vraiment
comment les choses se sont passées mais
du point de vue inuits donc ça c'est
extrêmement intéressant il le fait avec
beaucoup de franchise ou est-ce que
c'était un regard qu'on nous ne nous dit
jamais exactement
et c'est extrêmement intéressant
vraiment ça c'est un essai c'est un
incontournable de 2019 je pense dans les
essais autochtone donc les conséquences
sur la commission la communauté inuite
la communauté crie un peu mais bon oui
l'hongrie c'est sûr que
donc les négociations donc c'est
vraiment une version qu'on doit on doit
entendre absolument incontournable
ensuite bien je vais plus au canada
anglais mais quand même intéressant donc
c'est danser sur le dos de notre tortue
dalian bêtasse un beau sac ex-thomson
donc elle elle parle de la nouvelle
émergence niche labèque donc de la
nation algonquine en général donc c'est
un essai qui traite de la réconciliation
on en parle souvent mais en fait ce
qu'elle dit c'est qu'on ne peut pas
seulement regarder la réconciliation
sous le jour du cadre constitutionnel
canadien il faut aussi prendre en compte
les traditions autochtones si on veut
arriver à quelque chose et le vous avez
que ça rejoint un peu ce que je pense
oui alors extrêmement intéressant la
hausse il ya vous l'avez choisi mais il
a été écrit en anglais en premier lieu
une traduction des traduit oui
absolument immenses comme celui de
monsieur young à claouey canada anglais
oui absolument
il ya aussi les cd colonisé le canada
qui est fait par deux activistes de la
colombie-britannique donc arthur manuel
et un rôle a dit que direction juste pas
me tromper
donc c'est un essai qui va faire un peu
le portrait d'un demi-siècle de
militantisme autochtones au pays
donc depuis les années 70 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui le militantisme autochtones
souvent on pense que ça a commencé avec
la crise tout comme et il ya plein de
choses qui sont arrivées à 20 ans ça
c'est extrêmement intéressant d'un point
de vue historique le portier est on sûr
le québec se retrouve à l'intérieur
trois jours oui oui à quelque part parce
que soient les courants qui sont qui
sont arrivés jusqu'à nous un moment
donné d'une certaine manière et le
dernier s'éteint le classique des
classiques
c'est un livre qui a été publié en 1976
j'étais même poney mais c'est je suis
une maudite sauvage is ii and an tan
capech oui
donc si l'utilité ou et était donc sa
mémoire d'encrier incontournable si vous
pouvez lire quelque chose c'est
extrêmement intéressant
madame k pêche ont vécu la première
partie de sa vie donc en territoire et
tout d'un coup est arrivé tranquillement
l'école la police
le système de justice dont etc et elle
va parler de tout ce qui se passe de
cette colonisation le comme elle l'a
vécue avec énormément de franchise elle
n'y va pas par quatre chemins
oui oui oui l agent jose luis garcia est
en fait des vieilles avec aujourd'hui je
relisais et et elle parle de son fils
qui s'est fait arrêter par la police
mais là il va passer par les tribunaux
mais on fait vraiment des liens avec ce
qui s'est passé à val d'or notamment
donc c'est encore très d'actualité
extrêmement travaillée on pourrait faire
le parallèle entre dans le livre de
madame k pêche est votre livre michel en
fait oui ces deux femmes là ont vécu la
même chose mais vous avez été beaucoup
plus doux quand vous avez raconté son
histoire même s'il faisait ou jeu là
ouais mais mais oui mais c'est que c'est
que c'est nous aussi la dette
c'est comme ça qu'ils étaient même à ma
grand-mère les des gens chez nous que
j'ai c'est de coller un peu à ça mais on
comprend quand même la violence à
travers et même quand j'écrivais le lie
à donner justement quand arrive le
moment où la famille peut plus aller sur
le territoire où est-ce qu'ils sont
toujours allés en selle ou s'ils
arrivaient au maudit par terre puis elle
a monté la vie à péribonka belle
arrrivée resserre à la dhr à bâle
oui qui sont everton 2-1 chez vous on
est chez nous on bosse dix mois par
année aux passes dangereuses deux mois
par année hamas ou via c'est donc chez
nous c'est un honneur tant que je me
souvienne pire et cela quand je
décrirais cette scène-là la calade moi
je la sentais j'avais appelé isabelle en
soi ah oui c'est qu'avec ça que je t'emm
uddin
c'est normal il ya aussi que moi ce que
j'en étais comme comme réflexion ce
qu'elle est je pense que les autochtones
on a de la difficulté à accepter d'être
en colère souvent soit que se livrent
leurs jumeaux dit sauvage s ils datent
de 1976
mais on voit moins sont aujourd'hui
quoique ça commence à changer avec le
militantisme et tuer le mouvement ado
nos morts etc
mais les est en colère trop
revendicateurs
ça n'a pas toujours été bien acceptée
qui s'approcherait le chemin que qu'on a
choisi mais je pense que ça aussi ça
commence à changer parce que la colère
c'est quelque chose que c'est une
émotion que pour faire son deuil et pas
faut aussi passer par par la colère donc
quelque part je me dis que la colère est
aussi acceptable pour les premiers
peuples en colère
ça m'a fait beaucoup de bien de relancer
jal et j'avais vu ça à l'université lynn
et puis là je leur fais et et ça m'a
fait du bien je me dis ok cette colère
là elle est exprimée par quelqu'un
d'autre d'un autre à temps oui mais
c'est pas pour rien que des fois je me
sens comme ça ça fait du bien oui chers
qui devrait lever de machelen williams
puis j'ai lâché je voulais aussi parce
que bon on a vu cette conversation
isabelle mais moi je trouve que
quelqu'un comme tu dit ça fait du bien
mais c'est quand quelque chose qu'on n'a
plus qu'à auxquelles on n'a pas tant
réfléchi et parler que je me suis lavé
mandat joséphine - bah quand je n'ai
jamais forcé leur vie tout ce qui
t'arrive et je n'ai jamais fragile
m'avait dit si je peux passer ma vie
fort ça me fait beaucoup réfléchi ça
chez moi aussi je vais pas porter
d'habits fâché si bon c'est joséphine
bacon c'est quand même quelqu'un qui est
plus profonde a repris une expérience de
vie mais mais n'empêche que je pense que
le lien avec la colère
quelque part ça reste quand même quelque
chose qu'on réprime la plupart souvent
et je parce que que c'est nécessairement
toujours la bonne chose à faire donc je
vais on peut peut-être on n'a pas d'être
rejetés de provoquer des réactions
négatives des québécois
si si si on est trop si on réclame trop
mai
si vous voulez pas le faire vous leur
dites de lire un an tandis qu'à pêche le
fait clairement en effet alors il nous
reste très peu de temps mais avant de
partir julie vous travaillez sur un
nouvel ouvrage ce que je travaille il
est dans la tête mais je planche pas
dessus parce qu'en ce moment je faire
une histoire courte lors c'est très
intéressant pour vous autres stars mais
mais je suis de retour à l'école puis je
suis dans un programme intensif y en a
cinquante heures de cours semaine donc
lecture et ses tables étaient pour le
moment mais en même temps ce que je fais
en ce moment je fais le choix de
l'informatique
moi j'ai toujours eu une certaine
passion pour la science fiction pu me
projeter dans un futur rapproché sa
nourrice non et warrior oui ça c'est ça
qui est un peu normand d'anticipation
oui c'est une douce anticipations donc
oui c'est sûr que ça maintenant que je
comprends mieux comment les machines et
les augmentant fonctionne à vue disons
que ça va me servir vous ouvre à nouveau
- oui tout à fait ouais voilà parce que
riz qui m'énerve le plus qu'un auteur
qui maîtrise pas son sujet d'un montant
qui parle de science fiction pas compris
les fondamentaux de la science
j'aime pas la route celui là exact
michel vous travaillez sur quoi vous
ouais bah en fait j'ai commencé
tranquillement à l'écran moi j'ai un
roman c'est un peu comme julie j'y pense
ouais c'est une bonne chose commentera
penser avant le 15 mai je passe beaucoup
en fait puis quand je commence à écrire
c'est quand j'ai vraiment le bavaria le
thème parce que les personnages que je
développe pu apprécier l'histoire
puis les lieux où ça va se passer mais
faut que je sache que tout se soit pas
mal clair dans ma tête certains font des
plans j'ai envie moi quand je commence
un blanche n'est toujours pas le plan
devient le vraiment à aller chez une
amie
ça marche pas mais faut que j'aie le
plan au moins assez clair dans ma tête
je suis rendu pas mal là soit tu as roma
qui justement va s'intéresser à beaucoup
aux autochtones en milieu urbain et
justement toute la question
mais quand johann guillemain ipsos a
peut-être raison
de liberty city cantonné en milieu
urbain c'est quoi être un autochtone en
milieu urbain puis aussi la coupure avec
avec avec les les racines culturelles
qu'est-ce que ça laisse comme blessure
pour les gens qu'est ce que ça qu'est ce
que cela entraîne pour lui les
autochtones sont en milieu urbain j on
est on est nombreux à vivre en ville
d autres comme d'autres est aussi une
réalité parce qu'au québec souvent ces
six mois c'est une chose mais toujours
fragile à paladin indien pour les gens
souvent analysé c'est un autochtone
c'est une chose en particulier alors que
c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ça
l'identité maintenant je veux faire un
livre avec ça et aussi comment des
autochtones s'adapte maintenant avec
comme le lien avec le territoire est
plus le même aujourd'hui est que pour
voit beaucoup dans beaucoup de
communautés a été carrément brisé les
gens ont pu le même rapport avec les
territoires qu'ils avaient auparavant et
comme l'identité des autochtones est
tellement liée au territoire surtout
pour les innu qui est certain c'est est
un mode de vie qui était qui allait
au-delà de l'activité change
je vais être obligé de vous les gens
parce que j michel gym est obligé de
vous laisser aller parce qu'on va
bientôt se faire couper ou et en plus
vous êtes attendus à rimouski alors ce
sera long du livre de rimouski
donc là d'aujourd'hui demain
après-demain salon du livre des
premières nations salon du livre de
montréal vous êtes partout donc j'invite
les gens à aller va mieux contrer merci
beaucoup d'être venu aujourd'hui
bonne route julie merci également
beaucoup merci d'être venu nous
présenter vos deux ouvrages de parler
littérature avec nous très agréable et
isabelle merci beaucoup c'est prévu pour
quand votre livre mars mars 2020 donc on
va le suivre et entend en attendant
toutes les deux isabelle vous serez pas
au salon du livre mais julie vous allait
tout salon du livre de montréal
oui j'ai pu retenir c'est exactement
donc semaine prochaine ils ont appris
j'ai récup et on ne changera pas alors
qu'ils ont fait mal en bon salon à tous
les deux et puis isabelle merci beaucoup
et on se retrouve très bientôt sur ce
plateau
je m'appelle la n'arrivons portez vous
bien et à très bientôt donc et bonne
lecture sur tout